la scène s'ouvre
à celles et ceux
qui rêvent d'un monde meilleur
aux passionnés aux curieux aux oreilles
qui regarde vers ailleurs
aux idéaux aux missions à ceux qui même
sous le fracas dans celle rythment le
quotidien des projets des idées qui on
suggère la cadence
les idées
inspirées mots que l'on couche sur le
papier
qu'inspirent les actes qui s'élève dans
nos vies qui inspire les expériences
qu'on transmet à autrui qui s'en
inspirent pour créer ses propres idées
c'est ainsi que le voyez vous un cercle
vertueux c'est ainsi qu'on essaye
toujours de faire mieux entre stress
face à l'enjeu excellé dans vos yeux
alors certes ce n'est pas un jeu mais
quand on sait que cet art vaut mieux
qu'un succès sans âme et creux on
s'excuse pas d'être harmonieux
elle est noble la scène elle témoin une
de celle qu'on vit au quotidien
elle reflète nos actes dans une pièce
jouée à pile ou face dont nous sommes
les comédiens elle est un monde la scène
une énergie qui se construit dans le
bien comme dans le mal elle aspire à le
changer lorsqu'il s'est garé dans un
trou noir aux idées trop terne pour
briller parmi les étoiles
pardon
je voulais pas être négatif
on est là pour changer le monde pas pour
le rendre dépressif j'ai 180 secondes
pour me plier à l'exercice en cours et
d'idées trophée conde pour que les
miennes soit 1 précise seulement c'est
quoi changer le monde
je veux bien mais j'ai même pas changer
une roue de vélo alors c'est quoi
changer le monde j'en arrivai même
demandé ce n'est pas plus simple d'en
racheter un nouveau alors dit moi j'ai
encore crédibles pour changer le monde
ou doivent veiller à ce que le monde ne
me change pas mais je ne me range pas du
côté des résignés ce soir j'ai entendu
trop d'enjeux parler de discours
raisonné pour que mettais mon penche
parmi les idées courtes erronées les
héros naissent de leurs actes les vraies
promesses sont des pactes envers nous
mêmes envers nos rêves envers nos peines
quant au reste au sein des cartes
cartésien idéaliste il n'y a de bons
tireurs que celui qui sait choisir la
bonne cible regardez bien chaque nom sur
la liste et rappelez-vous que tout cela
ne serait pas possible sans les
adhérents les adhérentes les bénévoles
l'air car vivant les âmes et dante label
école du don de soi qui prend du sens
quand dans l'assaut tout le monde a sa
com par essence dans la peau les
salariés premier à l'heure qui servent
alliés éprouvées valeur travail et pour
prôner les leur savoir-faire sans
paroles en l'air les mécènes messieurs
mesdames merci cells et ceux qui font
don sans kit aide ne serait pas aussi
somptueux aussi grand le public c'est
important de pupille tant de temps
pendant lequel nos paroles résonnent
qu'elle porte et or est elle si on
parlait devant personne alors dites moi
et il quelqu'un ici qui n'est pas
vécue chaque talk comme un monde à part
un voyage pour les idées un nouveau
regard une belle édition touche à sa fin
bienvenue au point de départ des
nouvelles visions des lendemains qui ne
croit pas au hasard mais à la
transmission à l'humain à la puissance
du partage aux valeurs qui guident de la
mission de bretagne des larges ils elles
étaient onze sur scène 200 backstage
vous êtes 2000 présent si nombreux
derrière les écrans celles et ceux qui
manquent à l'appel à qui nous en
parlerons comme au temps de battement
d'aile qui font de l'effet papillon
notre plus belle raison de croire que
c'est ensemble que l'on fonde bien plus
que des espoirs des idées qui changent
le monde
[Applaudissements]